it's great to welcome to the program
today Erik Durkheim er who's a professor
of psychology at the University of
Virginia we are going to be talking
about some of the controversies that are
now very very prevalent in some enclaves
of the internet and not only there
including about genetics and environment
and IQ but I think maybe first just so
we're all on the same page let's talk a
little bit about the genesis of what we
now know is the modern IQ test what it
can tell us and sort of what it cannot
tell us well I mean the genesis of it if
that's where we're gonna start is back
at the turn of the 20th century it was
invented by French and American
investigators largely in the context of
first testing army recruits and later
testing immigrants in the United States
probably the concept of intelligence as
opposed to intelligence test themselves
date back a little bit further than that
to someone in Francis Galton was
Darwin's cousin as a matter of fact and
was a controversial figure but in many
ways an uncontested genius in the 18th
Victorian 1870s navies and I I think the
place to start with IQ is you commonly
hear people who either believe that IQ
is this deep dive into what a human
being is capable of on one hand and then
people on the other side who say that
it's meaningless and that it's just what
the IQ test measure or it's just a
measure of how much money your parents
make or something along those lines and
I think the important thing and thinking
clearly about IQ is steering a
reasonable course between those two
extremes
IQ is a is a measurable characteristic
of people yawn
any doubt if if you I mean there's a you
know a lot of technical stuff but if you
give people a series of mental tests of
almost any kind on average people who do
well on one mental test is are gonna do
well on other mental tests and if you
you know a slightly more sophisticated
way taking average across all those
mental tests you get an IQ score and
what that IQ score is for sure we can
talk about whether it's anything more
than this but what it is for sure is a
measure of how good someone's cognitive
functioning is right now at the time
they took tests it's it's a description
of someone like finding out how
depressed they are or anything else that
a psychologist might measure and I think
if you if you view IQ this way a measure
of how well somebody is capable of
thinking at the moment it's not really a
very controversial idea because anybody
can look around them and see that some
people are are functioning at a higher
level than others some people have
bigger vocabularies and can solve harder
problems and do better plans I mean we
all we all know that I think what makes
the idea controversial is this idea that
IQ test somehow measure this deep thing
called innate intelligence that it's
it's not just how well you're doing
right now but this inner thing that
you're born with that constrains how
well you possibly can do in the world
and I wouldn't I don't want to say
there's no evidence that that's true I
mean there are people sensible people
have done tried hard things to show that
that's true but it's certainly it's far
from obvious that that's true and it's
very very difficult show that it's true
can you talk a little bit about I'm sure
there's much more that could be said on
that but there's a lot that the sort of
follows from this that I want to use as
sort of our baseline for establishing
our conversation there is this idea that
iq maybe represents some kind of
universal measure of intelligence that's
independent of culture or geography or
what-have-you and then there's another
view that there is some test bias which
is that the test itself is biased
towards individuals from certain parts
of the world with certain education and
that it's not as universal as some might
point to can you give us an
understanding of that yeah I mean I
don't I don't think it's a question on
which there's an absolute answers
I think it's broadly true that among
modern people people who live in the
developed world certainly in North
American Europe and in large parts of
East Asia as well where people are
basically educated basically abstract
thinking oriented basically book
oriented the biases in IQ tests are in
fact barely small
I mean IQ didn't as far as that goes IQ
tests are much better than they were
when they were first created when they
were obviously biased and if it's really
not the case I don't think that IQ tests
are at least in obvious ways biased
against say or emeritus or something
like that
now another somewhat farther out part of
the IQ world is people who think it's
legitimate to wander out into
sub-saharan Africa somewhere with a IQ
test kit and find people who I've never
been to school or only a rudimentary
school had may or may not be illiterate
and and the whole culture of taking a
test on which you try to get the right
answer to get a high school
or just doesn't make any sense and I
think push that hard yes tests are
obviously biased and that's important
because there are people who actually do
that and take the results seriously
which i think is a huge mistake
so among most of us
I don't think test bias is a huge issue
in understanding why some people get
higher IQ scores than others fair enough
you've your work has shown that or claim
to show that the environment accounts
for about 60% of the IQ variance among
low-income children so let's start with
that sixty percent number question one
is what accounts for the variance of the
other forty percent uh well I mean
they're very broadly genetics though
well there there's a there are a lot of
things to say about that you have to be
very I Q like everything on any any
miserable difference you can measure in
people is to one extent or another
correlated with our genes and all that
says is that sort of where we start in
life and the biological input that we
become winds up correlated with where we
went end up it doesn't mean that there
are genes for IQ or per se or anything
like that
now when you when you talk about those
percentages those percentages are a very
very complicated thing because it's it's
it's you know we're talking about a
quantity that's called a heritability
that varies from zero to one and tells
you tells you within a lot of
complications about the proportion of
differences in people that are accounted
for by differences in our genes i one
way i like to think about it is
it tells you how much more similar we
would all be if we were all clones and
and it's easy to think when you start
thinking about these numbers that IQ or
any trade has a heritability and we do
science to find out if the heritability
of IQ is 60% or 70% or 40% or 20% and
that's wrong IQ doesn't have a
heritability the heritability of IQ
depends on the situation but you measure
it and it and that depends on how much
people very genetically and
environmentally
so in fact if you gave an IQ test to a
bunch of clones I mean that's not
possible in humans you know a huge set
of identical twins everybody exactly was
saying the heritability would be zero
because everyone is genetically the same
and differences in genes can't account
for everything so anyway coming back to
our study when people have computed
those heritability some twins in the
past it's been very common it's very
hard to get poor twins in twin studies
for a variety of reasons they don't
volunteer for the study of poor families
have better things to do and and we've
we found we really find it there there
is a large American twin study that
included a lot of twin children raised
in poverty and what we found in that
study is that among very poor children
the heritability of intelligence the
proportion that seemed to be accounted
for by genes was very very low as lower
than 40% it was close to 0% in the
poorest children and then as you proceed
up to through the middle class into the
upper middle class there weren't a lot
of rich people in this study genes
became more and more important accounted
for more and more of the variance we're
so by the time you got to the upper
middle class things are almost
completely reversed and that that
finding just by the way has replicated
quite well in the United States where we
have a lot of economic and educational
inequality not so much in Europe where
they have a better safety net but
that fits I think with a lot of common
sense thinking about intelligence which
suggests that it's bad environments are
much more important for intelligence
than good environments it's it's it's a
lot I don't mean to be flip about it but
it's a lot easier to make someone dumber
than it is to make him smarter because
things that go wrong are much more
important and what I think is what I
like about that finding is that it gives
us a way to take the overall genetics of
IQ seriously whereas at the same time
understanding the critical importance of
things like poverty and bad environments
and the negative effects that those can
have on children while they're growing
up
let's pause our conversation there we've
been speaking with Eric Durkheim ER
who's a professor of psychology at the
University of Virginia we'll continue
our conversation with him tomorrow we're
continuing our conversation with Eric
Durkheim ER who's a professor of
psychology at the University of Virginia
where I'd like to pick up our
conversation if we can is first to sort
of get into the topic of race and IQ
before we talk about the meaning and
causality question one is are there
observable differences in IQ measured by
race as race is understood in modern
Western society yep there are and can
you describe that in a little more
detail yeah so if you if you give an IQ
test to a sample of measure we'll talk
about the u.s. American blacks and
whites or or a test that is essentially
an IQ test even if it's not intended
quite as such like the SATs or something
like that blacks will score something
like two-thirds of a standard deviation
about 10 to 12 IQ points lower that's
just a fact
on average and of course the important
discussion is why that is right so my
immediate follow-up I mean given that so
we're working with the sort of same same
baseline of the data that a lot of
people who have become incredibly
interested in this topic over the last
three to five years start with my
immediate next question and you tell me
whether this is the correct next
question or whether there are
intermediate questions to look at is do
we have reason to believe that the that
the cause of those differences is race
itself uh well if you mean biological
race then no I by I believe strongly
that we don't I mean it certainly is
social aspects of race and the history
of slavery and discrimination let me in
some ways that's race but presuming you
mean race as a biological construct I
feel very strongly that it doesn't and
that it's in fact irresponsible for
people to speculate that it might be
it's and my strongest feeling about that
is that based on the kind of data that
we can generate in human beings it's
it's not it's not only that there's no
evidence that that's true oh that's the
case there is no evidence that that's
true it's also that there's no possible
evidence that it's true it's not like
we're waiting for somebody to complete a
study that's it's going to be decisive
well that was a maybe my next question
which is hypothetically what type of
evidence if you could imagine it would
tell us that IQ differences between
races are specifically because of race
is that even a possibility I mean here
here's the way I think that could turn
out to be true I mean and I don't and I
and my point is that this is very
unlikely to happen if if we summed and
what what doesn't exist even though IQ
is heritable like everything is ever
thing about people is heritable there
are no in the normal range
aside from Down syndrome and things like
that there are in the normal range the
difference between your IQ and mine
there are no known genetic mechanisms
that determine your IQ that oh well okay
this pretty you know David has genes XY
and Z and Erik has genes a B and C and
we know that it's always true that
people with X Y Z genes have higher IQs
that ABC genes and we especially if we
ever understood the mechanism because
you can see here's what X Y Z genes do
to your brain and enhance the neurons
etc etc etc and because of that people
with those genes are smarter pretty much
all the time not contingent on anything
else uh if that were true well then you
could find a group of people that had
those genes and a group of people that
didn't have those beans and say well the
difference between those groups seems
like it's caused by those gene I mean
and that might apply to American blacks
and whites and it might not but it's an
explained the difference between some
groups groups that have them in groups
that don't have but it's those
mechanisms that are exactly what's
missing all we know is that genes in
individuals are correlated with IQ at
the end of the day and we have
absolutely no reason why or how and
because of that we have no way of
knowing whether if the world changed you
know so if 200 years from now
slavery is finally far enough back in
the rearview mirror that it's not
affecting people anymore and
discriminate and Jim Crow and
discrimination - and all the racism that
still goes on today that's finally deep
in the past the the genetics of race
people have to have to say the
mechanisms of IQ are such that blacks
will still score low
on IQ tests and there's simply no way
there's simply no way to know that and
if you're just betting on the
probabilities there's no reason to think
like that something like that would ever
come out to be true you have to remember
that you know 120 years ago at the turn
of the century when IQ tests were first
coming online people from southern
Europe Italians and Greek people at
lower IQs and that man because those
were the people who were emigrating and
Jews for that matter and because those
were the people who were immigrating to
the United States who was a big deal and
people thought the exact same thing that
Wow though those people they have lower
IQs it must be because of their genes
and it's not that somebody's done a big
scientific experiment that showed oh no
no three people they're okay it's not
their genes after all it's just that
time has gone by and Greek immigrants
have recovered from whatever hardships
they were experiencing when they first
immigrated here and nobody thinks about
it anymore and in in the absence of any
other reason any reason to think
otherwise that that's what we should
expect to happen in the long run with
blacks and whites except of course the
what has been done to blacks over the
last 500 years in North America is is
far worse than what's been done to any
other group and it's gonna take more
these things don't change fast and I
think one of the problems is that these
kind of these kinds of deficits and
disadvantages change over a tiny period
that's the longer than an individual
human life
so we it's like watching the hour hand
on a clock you know and I think a big
part of the motivation for people who
think well god this has got to be
genetic is they've been looking at it
for 20 or 30 years and the gap hasn't
gotten it's gotten a little smaller but
it hasn't gotten all that much smaller
and that's what I wanted to ask you
about next I mean you've you've spoken
to
a variety of different people about this
issue I saw an interview you did with
stefan molyneux do you attribute bad
faith to the movement that wants to
explain IQ differences by saying they
are because of race or do you attribute
ignorance or this sort of short span of
time
that you're pointing out I can't I guess
I can't characterize everybody that
thinks that there are I mean one thing
I've become aware of and it'll happen
again
when this interview gets out on Twitter
I mean especially outside the
professional community there there are
just a lot of here in America people are
fascinated with race and for a lot of
people they're fascinated with race and
kind of a negative way and there are a
lot of racist people out there who just
want to believe that because it confirms
their their presuppositions about the
world in the in the professional world
that's more complicated I do know some
presumably professional people who I
think are motivated by racism on this
issue I know other people who you know I
think are motivated by a genuine
scientific impulse that there's this
persistent difference they want to
understand why it happens and and
especially in the you know in the in the
very contemporary world that I I find
there's a tendency on sort of the the
center-right if I can say it that way on
the academic center right to be it's
become so important to a lot of people
to not to give in to what they view as
the PC campus culture bla bla bla bla
bla that it's very important to them to
entertain seriously anything that seems
like a scientific hypothesis so when
somebody says well I'm a scientist and
I'm not a racist and I'm just so burly
investigating the possibility that the
IQ gap between the race
is scientific there are a lot of people
who feel a scientific responsibility to
take that idea seriously and I think it
I think I think it's wrong to do that
and I think they're making a mistake but
I don't think they're exactly racists in
doing it they're they're just putting
their commitment to academic freedom and
freedom of inquiry above their
importance of racist hypotheses and I
think that's a mistake but well I said
it I don't altima t think it's motivated
by racism and it they and and how the
balance of all those things work out
really differs from person to person
then in a way that's hard for me to
characterize broadly last thing I want
to touch on in the in the limited time
we have is the following
on the one hand you've said that it
could be a long time until the sort of
realities of humans on our planet change
such that this gap will be eliminated
you've also indicated that yes currently
the average intelligence for certain
races is higher and lower than for
certain others so my question is more of
a speculative one which is in the
immediate other than saying give it
another 400 years is there any
mathematical case that you have found is
the most effective or scientific case to
explain to those who seem convinced that
the gap is because of race innately to
sort of disabuse them of those beliefs
yeah well I think the the best way to
make that case is be a something called
the Flynn effect the Flynn effect is
something that was observed by the
Prospero psychologist Jim Flynn who
demonstrated that to over over the last
75 or a hundred years which is the
period of time in which people have been
taking IQ tests that are similar enough
that we can compare how they were doing
back then to how they're doing
now people have gotten over that period
of time everywhere you look people have
gotten way way smarter like like 20
points smarter and as countries go from
being pre-industrial agricultural
countries especially to post-industrial
modern countries there's a huge increase
in in average IQ that can't possibly be
genetic that's way way way too short a
time frame and that means that the
present-day gap between blacks and
whites is smaller than the average
difference between our grandparents
generation and today and so what that
tells you is that you know even though
that gap can be frustrating and hard to
change on the scale of how much people's
IQs change over time it's right smack in
the middle of what we expect to change
as our environment changes and to me
that that's the best reason to think
no this isn't a fixed aspect of people
it's something fluid that's changing all
the time we've been speaking with eric
tarr Kaymer he is a professor of
psychology at the University of Virginia
a very interesting topic and I look
forward cautiously to the feedback from
this interview Eric thank you so much
for talking to us about this yeah